hello everybody hope that you had a nice
weekend today is Monday so you know it's
time to start with the trading but
before I just start going into the
analysis that I can see in the chart now
I want to go first to Friday remember
that Friday we have about I think it was
11 UTC time an hour before non-farm
payrolls all right I warned you guys
that if the results were bad or in this
case if the results are good because
good news for the labor market are bad
news
because the FED needs that the labor
market cools off all right so the
results were very good for the workers
but that's bad for the Fed so the market
had to react to it and I was warning you
guys that if the results were were bad
for the market then what you were going
to see is this liquidity pool getting
retrace here okay the Confluence also
was the 50ma this purple line and then
you could open along here because of
course we had this liquidity pool in
mind at 29 600 and also this week over
here around 29 500 okay now what
happened the results were bad and price
indeed exactly that came lower you know
retrace this liquidity pool test the
50mm support and then bounce higher at
the at the 50 of the week so I was
around 29
425 I think it was that's when I closed
most of my trade and then the remaining
position I closed it on the top of the
liquidity pool which is around 29 650.
so that was a very good trick that I saw
that some of you took
um again guys none of these videos are
financially advice I think that you
should try to watch these videos to try
to
maybe gain a different perspective of
how somebody can analyze the market
because I know not many people chart
like this
um but you know it's not a signal I'm
not telling you long here take profits
here it's just my plan that's what I'm
doing okay then if you want to take that
and maybe use it as Confluence to your
analysis that's great but don't let my
analysis to be your analysis okay that's
not how this works because imagine if
I'm gone tomorrow then what have you got
from this nothing you have to try to
learn from these videos okay they are
free use them now let's see what happens
since then let me remove all of this
mess I'm interested on this anymore
in yesterday's Sunday update or posting
let's go to the four hour time frame the
idea that there was quite a lot of
liquidity and still above this Zone
because this Zone over here if you
notice the it's it's a strong resistance
you can see price gets reacted rejected
rejected rejected therefore in this area
if we come back to the sum Traders are
gonna Place more shorts so there is
gonna be a lot of liquidity here in all
the stop losses and liquidations from
high leverage Traders all right so
that's a liquidation Zone what a
liquidity so it's quite interesting but
of course we have this week we had this
week since the 26th of April I've kept
in My Chart all this time why because I
know the price goes back to the weeks it
always happens now you can check that
price hashtag the 50 of the week it
might still go to the hundred percent of
the week
because yes if you notice here and we go
to the Daily time frame look where we
are these 50ma is in the daily time
frame has been or support since the 21st
of April check here one two three four
five six retest a support right that's
what it's keeping us in this uptrend or
in this sideways move as you wanna say
oh
if we have a daily candle closing below
this 50 main okay then the next one can
test it as resistance and then truce me
we're gonna go lower where to
difficult to tell but I've always been
telling you guys
check out this level 25 300 I know it's
a level that many people have marked in
their chat but it makes sense why
because look at this we came to the zone
there was a sell-off boom welcome back
to the Zone another sell-off boom have
we tested this trend line as support no
it yet so the most likely thing is that
price maybe I mean we have some support
over here around 26
800. so yes we could come here and do
some sideways But ultimately we're going
to look at this level because if this
level if we test this level
and we bounce
okay that's good but if we break below
this
what's gonna be next I mean look at this
we have here a lot of liquidity of
liquidity pools all in this one only
zone is liquidity pools
um that takes you between 23 800 to 20
500. so lost this zone of 25 000 and yes
we're gonna probably see 22k ish okay
there is also a lot of Liquidations in
that zone in in hybrid Capital so that
adds some Confluence to the idea that 25
000 is the level to watch if we lose the
50 daily EMA okay let me remove all of
this sorry
um more let's go back into the folder
time frame okay we're again in the four
hour time frame
um I want you guys to to keep in mind
and I want this to be clear that this
projection this pulls up towards this
Zone it's only valid if we close again
above the daily 50ma otherwise
it's probably not going to happen all
right well if we see some kind of fake
out below the 50ma and then in the next
candle we close above it again then I'll
reconsider a scenario
if that happens I'll probably remove
this from my chart okay and then what I
mean with this is that if we come again
to this Zone we're gonna go past it I
have that very clear it's not gonna be
another reaction like this we're gonna
go above it
this being said okay you can see that
you know we've already tacked the 50 of
the week how with another week uh it's a
convincing not really to be honest uh
most weeks get filled so
ah
I don't like it I think I want to feel
again at least the 50 probably 100 so
let's go to the one or time frame let's
see what's going on there let's see what
I can see maybe why Asia did what London
is doing and maybe one New York those
all right let's go to the one hour time
frame here you can see clearly that AC I
made the move okay let's mark those
sessions this could be ACM uh this is
London London still got a couple of
hours left well the European season
is the biggest stock market in Europe
and then this could be New York all
right so what I see here is the
potential
London Halls if London closes this can
the next candles inside this box here
right so London will be holding
and maybe right at the start of the New
York says Universe look you could see
some kind of
sharp dump maybe towards this lows here
right right at the start of the system
and then
okay then this would well this this
would have been in then maybe Mondays
for smooth we'll see all right and then
in the New York City they might want to
shake out
all those Traders and scared us thinking
that we're going to go if this lose hold
or if they sweep this lows and then they
come back above it really quickly
okay something like this then that is
only sweeping the lows they're only you
know shaking out the market and then we
could see a reversal where to well to be
honest
there is for example a liquidity pool in
this Zone and that would be around 28
500 and if you check the 50ma you can
see that we are you know the charge is
looking to be overextended price doesn't
go down forever or up forever sometimes
it needs to retest the 50ma that's why I
say in my case as resistance in this
case so why not why couldn't we see
something like this during the New York
session you know maybe
some kind of false move here
towards this lows and then a sharp
reverse and hit the 50 EMA
that's also around well right now it's
about 28 576 you can see in the top left
in the corner what do you see the
indicator
um obviously it's gonna go down
um probably goes to 28
475 maybe a hundred dollars down until
the New York session starts uh but yes
why not we could see something like this
playing out today this is what I'm
keeping an eye on today of course do you
still need to go into into the 15
minutes time frame the five minutes time
frame because if we come again low to
this area what you don't want to see is
a bounce leaving a long week behind
because weeks get filled all right or
you don't want to see a massive large
green candle
you want to see a bounce that it's
organic that it's clean that it doesn't
leave any imbalances behind because if
it lives in imbalances behind it might
tell you hey we might come back to this
zone or we're gonna go lower but that's
what I'm keeping an eye on against the
financial advice do you don't research
make your own analysis
um this should only be uh some kind of
side Confluence like if I like if I was
an indicator nothing more than that so
anyway guys thank you so much for
watching and I'll see you soon